after more than 30 years in the Senate
after 53 years since she first won
elected office and just months shy of
her 90th birthday Democrat Senator
Dianne Feinstein has announced that she
will be retiring from politics in two
years
Senator Feinstein tweeted quote I'm
announcing today I will not run for
re-election in 2024 but intends to
accomplish as much for California as I
can through the end of next year when my
term ends even with a divided Congress
we can still pass bills that will
improve lives and then when asked about
her announcement Senator Feinstein told
reporters I haven't made that decision I
haven't released anything
at which point a staff member informed
her that she had in fact announced her
retirement which seemed to surprise the
senator who then said quote I didn't
know they put it out it is what it is I
think the time has come Senator
Feinstein's political contributions have
not always been positive
or defensible
or even coherent
but in honor of the longtime senator's
retirement I would like to play one of
my favorite clips from her more than
half century in politics in which
Senator Feinstein yelled at
eight-year-olds for being too annoyingly
liberal even for her some scientists
have said that we have 12 years to turn
this around well it's not going to get
turned around in 10 years what we can do
Senator it just doesn't get turned
around in 10 years you're looking at the
faces of the people who are going to be
living with these consequences are you
supposed to be for the people and by the
people and you know what's interesting
about this group
I've been doing this for 30 years I know
what I'm doing you come in here and you
say it has to be my way or the highway
I don't respond to that
I've gotten elected I just ran I was
elected by almost a million vote
plurality
and I know what I'm doing
so you know maybe people should listen a
little bit maybe they should you tell
those eight-year-old Senator Feinstein
especially that annoying teacher oh my
gosh the teacher who put the kids up to
it Dianne Feinstein is a big lib
and she's wrong about most things
but she is nevertheless long been one of
the most reasonable and pragmatic
members of her party that is not a
recommendation of her that is an
indictment of her party but either way
depressing as it sounds we are going to
miss Dianne Feinstein when she goes I'm
Michael Knowles this the Michael Noel
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Sean hartsell
who says there are always a bunch of
candidates that jump in but everyone
knows most of them don't have a chance
that's true
but in this race the point I keep trying
to underscore is that it really is
anybody's race the 2024 GOP Presidential
nomination I know every because nobody
likes anxiety nobody likes uncertainty
everybody just wants to decide that's
why you're seeing all the GOP pundits
they've decided okay we don't really
like Trump anymore the next guy looks
like DeSantis okay we're all on board
for DeSantis let's I like DeSantis I
think DeSantis is doing a great job I
don't have anything negative to say
about this antis but I do have something
negative to say about trying to end this
race before it begins this is not how
primaries work guys this is why this is
why pundits usually get these things
wrong is because they all jump at the
first glittery thing they see and they
don't realize that that political
primary campaigns just move in waves and
at some point almost every candidate
Rises up at least a little bit and then
most of them fall down and at this time
in the cycle in 2016 in 2012 in 2008 the
candidate it's who looked like they were
shoe-ins to get the nomination
were people who barely made it through
Iowa and New Hampshire and South
Carolina they were not the candidates
who ended up who ended up making it and
so yes it looks like some of the people
who announced maybe yesterday don't
really have a shot don't count them out
this could be anybody's race now when
you're faced with uncertainty one great
way to hedge your bets and diversify
your Investments is to check out gold
from Birch gold right now text Knowles
to 98 98 98 the U.S blew through the
31.4 trillion dollar debt ceiling last
month and still the White House refuses
to reduce spending with that amount of
money you could buy almost every home in
the United States pay for college for
over 80 million people and buy every
sports team out there think about this
to dig our country out of this mountain
of debt every single taxpayer would have
to write a check for 247
000 and it's only getting worse if
you're worried about the future of this
nation's economy you need to consider
diversifying into something Dependable
you need gold with Birch gold Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals text
nulls to 98 98 98 to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists with
an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings right now text
Knowles kwles to 98 9898 protect
yourself with gold today that is nulls
to 98 98 98
. speaking of grandmothers following up
on the Dianne Feinstein story speaking
of grandmothers there is a tick tock
that went viral yesterday that is so
beautiful it's it's heartbreakingly sad
but it's also really really beautiful we
cover on this show every conservative
covers on every single conservative show
these tick tocks of crazy young people
pushing their radical gender ideology
and we usually make fun of them
sometimes we have pity for them this is
my favorite one of these videos I have
ever seen it is of a young woman
who is confused about her sex who thinks
that she's a man reading a letter that
she got from her grandmother
hi so recently I texted my parents
because I'm gonna go go home for
Christmas and I said hey do you mind
calling me Mike when I come back for
Christmas
and then when I got home today I got
this letter from my grandma and it is
addressed to miss oldname
not actually
but you know I don't want to say my real
name on the Internet
Dearest
dead name
on this are Blessed Mother's Feast Day
I'm writing to tell you that I will not
address you as Mike my decision is
probably not a surprise to you Others
May comply with your request my anguish
in your chosen name and what that means
has to do with your Eternal Soul know
that I love you more than words could
ever possibly convey to you no matter
how you decide to identify yourself does
not change my deep love for you honey
because of my concerns for your soul and
your mental health I am spending more
time with Jesus's adoration the my
cousin's last names are doing the same
for you do you know how much you are
cherished and loved it would be a joy to
see you and be with you during the
coming Christmas
um celebration of her Lord's birth
I previously believed that the perfect
response to the transgender Madness did
not exist
I knew that there were some responses
that were better some responses that
were worse
this grandmother just showed us the
perfect response this is it this is how
you respond to any loved one any family
member any friend who tells you that he
or she is now transgender and says they
don't want to go by their real name and
they want to go buy some new fake name
and they want you to pretend that
they're the opposite this is the
response absolutely Flawless and the
girl who's clearly in a lot of pain and
confusion and has all sorts of mental
and spiritual problems I would imagine
too
she gives away the game at the very
first part of the video did you hear
that little bit
she did so unwittingly but she said I
want to be called Mike
but my grandmother addressed this letter
to miss
so and so I'm not going to tell you what
that name is because I don't want to use
my real name on the Internet
what'd you call it
I thought Mike was your real name I
thought that other name you know that
you were born with christened with
raised with your whole life I thought
that name was dead and gone and that but
you just admitted that that's your real
name because you know deep down that
that is your real name
and and you recognize that wanting to
deny your real name is wanting to deny
your real identity and it might give you
some kind of pleasure or temporary
Euphoria in escaping whatever problems
that you have in your life but it isn't
real
and there's nothing compassionate about
indulging fantasy
what the grandmother is demonstrating is
some of the purest compassion I've ever
seen because compassion means to suffer
with somebody and she's saying I have
anguish and I'm just going to kiss it up
and I'm going to spend more time with
our Lord in the Blessed Sacrament in the
videos it goes on a bit longer I did cut
part of it out just to fit into the show
and part of it uh the the grandmother
writes you know some of your cousins are
making personal sacrifices you know to
sort of Kiss It Up and to to also have
compassion with you it's absolutely
perfect that is real compassion and I
know it's very tempting I've thought
about it myself oh my gosh what if God
forbid one of my kids had to deal with
some of these mental problems and
spiritual problems how would I react and
I know I would be very very tempted
to call my kid whatever name he wanted
to go by and pretend he had whatever
pronouns he wanted to pretend I would be
very tempted to do that because you just
want to give your kid whatever he wants
my My Little Boy comes to me he says I
want chocolate
and I say no no you can't have one
chocolate no seriously you want okay
here's some chocolate this is very hard
to say no to your kids but that
grandmother is the one exhibiting true
compassion true care speaking of women
of a certain age
and kids Chelsea Handler also went viral
yesterday Chelsea Handler is an alleged
comedian she was subbing in on The Daily
Show she's made a big segment about how
happy she is that she doesn't have any
kids
this is a day in the life of a childless
woman I wake up at 6am I remember that I
have no kids to take to school so I take
an edible masturbate and go back to
sleep I wake up at 12 30 pm and get
ready for a busy day of doing whatever
the I feel like I put on my most
impractical and stylish shoes since I
won't be chasing a child around the
grocery store I go to my fav spot in
Paris to grab a croissant I do a
meditation sesh on the plane since I
have no screaming kids allowing me all
the Time in the World to become
enlightened the weightlessness of my
existence has granted me superhuman
Powers I teleport myself back home then
I get ready for a night out with
whatever hot guy I met on Raya that
morning I call up a babysitter and tell
her that I don't need her since I still
don't have kids now it's time for a
workout so I hit Mount Everest for a
quick climb I invent a time machine go
back in time and kill Hitler crazy
bastard it's amazing what you can do
when you have this much free time and
that's a day in the life of a childless
woman
so everybody's reacting to this video
right now
I think a lot of people are missing the
point though and and maybe Chelsea
Handler is missing the point I don't
know but but what's interesting about
this video is not what she says at the
beginning of the video which is she says
oh I just do whatever I want I wake up I
pleasure myself I I drink a coffee I go
back to sleep I snooze the alarm that's
not what's interesting is what happens
in the middle and at the end of the
video when she starts just making stuff
up and fantasizing oh and then I fly to
Paris and then I go kill Hitler and then
I do this and then because
what she is demonstrating is that the
the promise of not having kids the idea
that you can just constantly amuse
yourself and do whatever you want the
things that you're going to do without
kids are so much more important than all
the all the all the drudgery that you're
going to have to engage in when you do
have kids that that is a fantasy you
can't really do all of that probably the
only real part of that video is the
first five or six seconds when she says
I I sleep in late because I'm kind of
depressed and I just pleasure myself a
little bit and then that's that's the
reality of it and then the fantasy and
the delusion is what comes afterwards I
don't know maybe I'm reading too deeply
into this I don't know that Chelsea
Handler meant the video in this way
almost certainly she did not but that's
what it's expressing what it's
expressing is the the joys and delights
that you think you are going to get out
of shirking responsibility and denying
your natural longings and and turning
your love Only onto yourself and not
giving it to anybody else
that's all illusory that's not really
going to happen
now when you want to prepare for you and
your family you got to check out Jace
medical go to jacemedical.com enter code
Knowles if the last couple of years has
taught you anything it is that the
supply chain is quite Fragile the FDA
just declared a global shortage of
medication and warns that critical
antibiotics are an extremely short
supply across the United States we all
had a good laugh when there were
shortages of toilet paper remember
otihihi then it got kind of annoying
actually when it when when our supplies
diminished and then there was that baby
formula shortage remember things weren't
quite so funny then what about when
there's a shortage of emergency
medications such as ibuprofen you need
to be prepared for anything and our new
partners at Jace medical are here to
help Jace medical helps you get a
long-term supply of prescription
medication it's a great way to start
preparing to start with that Jace case
it's a pack of five different courses of
antibiotics that you can use to treat a
whole host of bacterial illnesses
including UTIs respiratory infections
sinusitis skin infections and all you've
got to do is fill out a simple online
form your info will be reviewed by a
board certified physician and your
medication will be dispensed by a
licensed pharmacy at a fraction of the
regular cost be like the noses be
prepared get the Jace case right now
gives you peace of mind you can know
that your family will have what you need
during a crisis
I want you to be prepared for anything
China invades Taiwan there goes the
supply chain okay go to jacemedical.com
enter code Knowles right now at checkout
for a discount on your order
jacemedical.com promo code Knowles
George Bernard Shaw had a great line
about that Chelsea Handler video George
Bernard Shaw is a socialist playwright
who lived long before Chelsea Handler
was born but he had a great line about
the the kind of life that she's
envisioning saying well when I don't
have kids I can do whatever I want he
said describing hell he said
here there is no hope and consequently
no Duty no work nothing to be gained by
praying nothing to be lost by doing what
you like
hell in short is a place where you have
nothing to do but amuse yourself
and that is hell we all know that
we all know that because we were all in
school and you remember in school
sometimes you'd get a week off
spring break or winter break or I don't
know whatever and that sounded really
great you didn't have any school work
and you didn't have to wake up early and
then you just stay in pajamas all day
and play video games and do whatever you
want and it was really really great for
that first day oh man it was fabulous
and then even that second day that was
pretty fun and then that third day
you're starting to get kind of bored and
feeling kind of gross and lethargic by
the fourth day you start to get Cabin
Fever you start to unless you were on
some Excursion with your family or
something maybe then you could be
stimulated but if you're just hanging
around the house like most people were
you thought oh this isn't great this
isn't fun I got nothing to do
I I often go back in in these
analyzes of of the problems of popular
culture I often go back to Grand Theft
Auto
this it was one of the few video games I
ever really got a kick out of because it
was just so over the top it wasn't that
you went and you did a mission and you
uh I don't know had a donkey throw
barrels at squirrels and it was it was
just regular people in the street and
your your job in the game was to go rob
people kill pedestrians run over people
pick up hookers I'd do deal drugs it was
just all the worst it was so shocking
and there was there was a weird
Phenomenon with this game which is
if you played the game and you were just
kind of going around doing all the stuff
that would titillate little teenage boys
rather quickly it became pretty boring
and and that's what happens in real life
too that's the consequence of nihilism
when you just think there's no purpose
to anything we're all just walking
around here randomly as a kind of cosmic
accident and then we're gonna go take a
dirt nap and turn to worm food
then you become pretty sad that's why
I'm not going to make fun of the Chelsea
Handler video is that's just a terribly
tragically sad life
and it's not that you need kids to lead
a good edifying gratifying life a lot of
people can't have kids a lot of people
choose not to have kids if they take
religious orders the consecrated single
hood or anything like that
but you you do have to live your life
for more than just sleeping in and
pleasuring yourself that will not make
you happy
would you look at Hunter Biden you know
the proof of this is just looking at
Hunter Biden this is a guy with every
advantage in life he had a little
tragedy without question when he was
young but he had a ton of advantages and
he squandered all of it and he did the
drugs and he picked up the hookers and
he sold his father's influence and he
made a lot of money in Shady ways and he
just pursued his own desires and he just
he just physically looks terrible it
used to be a kind of a good looking guy
he now physically looks terrible that is
hell hell is the place where you have
nothing to do but amuse yourself
speaking of raising children
it's getting harder and harder to tell
the difference between parity and
reality
I I was flicking through the social webs
yesterday and I see this representative
from South Dakota South Dakota State Rep
Aaron Healy and she tweets out
extremist group Family Heritage Alliance
said this morning that the safest place
for kids are in families that have a
married mom and dad what a dangerous and
Un-American belief
and I I assumed before I reacted I just
kind of assumed this was
parody
and I looked and said Democrat state
representative so it could still be
parody
one of my favorite accounts on Twitter
is Dr Ann lesby
and for a while I thought this was a
serious account and I started looking I
said wait Dr Ann lesby is that
something a little off about that I
don't know maybe it's a series these
days it's impossible to tell isn't it
but then I looked Aaron Healy is a real
person
and she says
that the idea that the safest place for
kids is with a married mom and dad is
dangerous and Un-American because why
because everybody knows that the best
way to raise kids is in a molecule
commune with three dudes Four Chicks two
and a billy goat is that what
we're saying does anybody seriously
believe that no not even the
transsexuals not even the billy goat
believes that everybody knows that a
child does best
being raised by a mother and a father
joined together in marriage in
perpetuity for the good of the spouses
and the sake of the generation and
education of children everybody knows it
and I know there are some people
listening right now who might say well
no it's not the best in every situation
no it's literally the best in every
single situation
is it is it better to be raised by a
single mother no it can be done there
are heroic single mothers out there
who overcome difficult odds if a husband
walks out or something
but it's not ideal it's not better than
a married mother and father single
father no not better than a married
mother and father two homosexuals no two
lesbians no how do we know that that's
not better I know the libs now try to
say well actually you know actually
studies show that children raised by
homosexual men or do they do much much
better than ever you know on every
measurement uh then children raised in
families
that's obviously not true
because the implication of that is that
women have nothing to contribute to
child rearing
if that's true if you want to try to
make the labor argument that two dudes
raising a child is as good or better
than a family raising a child then the
inevitable logical conclusion of that is
that mothers have nothing to contribute
to the raising of children is that
really anybody's position
seriously no
we're two lesbians oh so we're really
going to say fathers have nothing to
contribute to the raising of children
yeah how is fatherlessness turned out in
in our society go look around the
prisons how is fatherlessness turned out
go look around the school Shooters his
father listeners turned out really well
go look at all the women on only fans in
all sorts of terrible sexual situations
has fatherlessness worked out really
well no of course not nobody believes
this
but it's apparently a dangerous and
Un-American no the dangerous belief
is the lie that children do not
need to be raised by both a mother and a
father
ideally married ideally their natural
mother and father though in some cases
children have bad situations or the
parents can't take care of them and then
you have adoptive parents take over and
that's a wonderful thing
but not a single adoptive parent
ideally
certainly not from infancy not two dudes
not two chicks a mother and a father
because because men and women both have
something to contribute to child rearing
this is a fact and you don't need
studies to back it up and you don't need
some mainstream media to write an
article about it we all know that that's
true we all agree with it
the people who say otherwise are simply
lying to themselves it's like that woman
that poor young woman suffering in the
transgender video with the grandmother
who says I'm Mike now I'm Mike that's
I'm I'm really Mike stop calling me by
my real name
oh what was that
that was you admitting that you know
this is all a delusion
you know you know deep down we all know
we should be able to admit that as well
speaking of the transgender Madness
the most important story on transgender
Madness in many many months
if if not longer
has it just been broken by the crane
Brothers
and David Cohn by the whole Crane and
Company show and you're going to think
this is kind of surprising because
grainy company is a sports show why is a
sports Show Breaking a really important
transgender story
I I've heard about this story ever since
uh Jake and David came into my office
the other day and and Blaine popped in
too it was just like they were all like
you're not going to believe this story
that we have it has to do with
will Thomas that gigantic hulking dude
who swims through the the pen swim team
against the women
I
uh tomorrow I'll give some analysis on
it tomorrow in the meantime here's just
a little teaser from the crane guys
if we let it there will be men
pretending to be women that ruin women's
sports but ranking first was the person
I had never heard of before and of
course this name was Leah Thomas Leah
Thomas did in fact formerly swim on the
men's team for three years I thought
surely the NCAA wouldn't let this person
compete with us the NCAA official looks
at me and says great job y'all tied um
The Trophy goes to Leah and he said well
for photo purposes Leah has to have it
wow Leah Thomas who used to be will
Thomas is now dating someone that used
to be a man that's now a woman and they
consider themselves lesbians very
interesting Dynamic the things they
practice actively are interesting they
cut off parts of their mail Parts but
left other parts these testicles are in
a jar stop we were being sidelined to
validate the feelings and the identity
of a man
so the the body parts in the jar is is
pretty gross and the weird uh
romantic relationships pretty weird the
craziest part of the interview is not
even in that clip and I don't want to
spoil it go watch it on grain and Co the
most significant craziest part of the
interview
is not even in that teaser go check it
out right now cranny company the
interview's out this morning it's
available to watch on their YouTube
channel or you can listen on Apple
podcast Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts
speaking of
caring for others let's get to the news
story that matters in my view really the
only news story that matters right now
that the establishment media are
refusing to talk about that would be the
poisonous train explosion in the town in
Ohio that is affecting potentially 10
percent of the water supply of the
United States a ton of Farmland in the
United States and the media are talking
about Little Green Men from Mars they
don't want to talk about this story
what happened here how on Earth did it
train that was carrying all of this
hazardous material a million a million
pounds of vinyl chloride was it was it
pounds or gallons I don't even remember
a ton of vinyl chloride along with all
of these other really dangerous
chemicals not only does it crash and
start leaking into the town they set it
on fire creating phosgene poison gas
from World War one and hydrochloric acid
in the atmosphere animals dropping left
and right can you imagine the poison in
this town and how far it's going out
beyond the area why did it happen well
according to one local hazardous
materials specialist near by the site
not from East Palestine itself but from
Youngstown Ohio
they did it to reopen the track
we basically nuked the town with
chemicals so we could get a railroad
open I was kind of
surprised that when they quickly told
the people they can go back home but
then said if they feel like they want
their their homes tested they can have
them tested I would have far rather they
did all the testing there's a lot of
what-ifs and we're going to be looking
at this thing 5 10 15 20 years down the
line and wondering see cancer clusters
could pop up you know well water could
go bad
so his view is they nuked the town to
get the track open the local authorities
who were trying to defend this action
are saying no no we did it because we
were afraid that it could explode and
cause even more
danger to the residents either way
though
we are now being told by the authorities
that the town is totally fine it's the
the air levels it's no big deal the
poison in the air don't worry about it
we saw a mushroom cloud a black mushroom
cloud over this town in Ohio but no it's
okay now you can go back home if you
want to get your house tested fine but
you know you don't need to worry about
it too much nothing to see here move
along Move Along finally mayor Pete who
is the least successful Transportation
secretary in history
in in is in particular in this regard
you think about all the airline problems
we've had under his tenure you think
about the this terrible disaster with
the railroad under his tenure you think
about the supply chain issues under his
tenure the way you know Pete Buda judge
is the least successful Transportation
secretary in history is he's the only
one who has been notable
name me other Transportation secretaries
ever in American history
I could name maybe one other one you
just don't think about the
transportation secretary except mayor
Pete is so terrible at his job and he's
even if you don't want to blame all
these problems on him he's been so
terrible in the response to these
tragedies that he's actually become
notable I don't know maybe the reason
Pete's been so slow to respond is he's
busy chest feeding his children maybe I
don't maybe he's on his paternity leave
has gone on past six months maybe it's
now we're approaching a year and a half
I don't know what the problem is but the
guy clearly can't do his job so finally
now I think it's 12 Days Later
I guess he he responded yesterday so
call it 11 days after the accident Pete
butterjudge has finally expressed his
concern mayor Pete says quote I continue
to be concerned about the impacts of the
February 3rd train derailment near East
Palestine Ohio and the effects on
families in the 10 days since their
lives were upended through no fault of
their own it's important that families
have access to useful and accurate
information yeah that is that is would
have been nice if they had that access
sooner than 10 days after the accident
might have been nice if the
transportation secretary expressed his
concern a little bit sooner but they're
not concerned
nobody's really can the the
transportation secretary is not
concerned the Biden Administration is
not concerned The Establishment media
are not concerned and do you know why
because of who these people are
who lives in East Palestine Ohio
the deplorable irredeemable bitter
clinging
fly over country peons who don't matter
to the people in Washington DC or New
York or Los Angeles or San Francisco
that's why if this had happened near New
York City Washington DC
San Francisco Los Angeles you know there
would have been a national state of
emergency declared you would have had
all of the emergency response teams on
the ground this would be that the Press
would be all over it but no this is the
flyover people who oh their water's
poisoned oh their air is poisoned all
their animals are dying ah well
it's fine we've we've been calling for
years for small town America to die I
guess this will just hurry up the
process
add on to this that what was it one or
two years ago there was a movie that
came out called White Noise I think
about this exact thing happening
about a trained derailment and all sorts
of terrible chemicals going up into the
air in an Ohio town it's kind of it's
pretty weird
and and I don't think you need to pull
out your tinfoil hat to say oh this is a
massive conspiracy Ram I'm not opposed
to conspiracies ever since covid and the
Dr fauci of it all basically there's
nothing you could tell me about our
government that I wouldn't believe but
you don't need to go there you can just
point out
that people the the people who make our
culture
have a sort of fantasy
that Middle America flyover country just
sort of goes away terrible things happen
to them they get a kick out of it it's
entertaining it's amusing but nobody
really cares let small town America die
that's what they say oh your jobs are
shipped overseas I learned to code
get out of there oh you bitter clay
you're probably racist you're you're the
kind of people you're not the future of
the future of America
is in high-rise buildings in pods in New
York
and all the big cities forget about Ohio
that's why
no one seems to care about this issue to
my mind the most important news story in
the country right now no one seems to
care about that because no one seems to
care about those people
certainly no one very few people in
positions of power do
I feel where Martha's Vineyard different
story now what is the story that the
establishment media are focusing on
what's the UFOs look at all the UFOs oh
boy
we had that Chinese spy balloon that
Biden let fly over the whole country but
now we're just picking off objects left
and right
now according to NBC News
the U.S intelligence community's leading
explanation for the three recent UFOs
that were shot down over North America
is that they were being used for
commercial or benign purposes
according to the White House
so that the one that was not being used
for a commercial or benign purpose the
one that was a Chinese spy balloon that
was going over sensitive military
targets and collecting data all across
the country that one we let keep flying
but then the other objects that Biden's
plucking out of the sky right now
they're nothing they're fine
sounds about right there are various
theories here
and you're going to hear more of them in
the coming days because the White House
keeps changing its Story the new theory
is that the the Biden Administration
actually watched this
Chinese spy balloon take off
all the way over in East Asia it took
off and they followed it long before it
entered U.S airspace and they weren't
just tracking it they were jamming the
communications and don't worry they're
in control they figured it out and then
finally just because someone happened to
see it in Montana they had to shoot it
down but they were just there in control
don't worry
now that was that's the news story
before that story we were told oh these
Chinese spy balloons they happen all the
time
but but we we didn't really know about
it then but it happened under Trump but
we didn't know about it under Trump but
we now know that that happened under
Trump because we want to Loop Trump into
the okay before that was the story the
story was oh these shiny spy balloons
they come across here all the time and
it's no big deal yeah don't no we know
about it's okay it's no big deal don't
don't worry about it and before that it
was what
we don't know what it is and it's just
pathetic it's just looks like
sheer incompetence
and the the impulse for people
who believe that everything is planned
out by our genius omnipotent lives in
the government
they always go to the most nefarious
explanation
this is all that's all planned and and
it gives people Comfort because they
feel that the government is in total
control I don't think these guys are in
total control I think they have no idea
what end is up I'm not sure Joe Biden
knows what his own name is
speaking of the president speaking of
people who want to be president again in
Joy Behar
and the cackling hands at the view are
somewhat impressed by one of the latest
nominees for the presidency that would
be Nikki Haley
this is part of the Invasion of the Body
Snatchers you know there are these there
are these politicians on the right who
now have become like mentally crazy you
know but our problem is that you know
Not only was she a big Trump supporter
and like she's an election denial too
isn't she at one point at one point but
she changed she flip-flopped on that
yeah but she also backed Herschel Walker
one of the worst candidates we've ever
had I mean second only May or second
only to George Santos maybe yeah you
know that was terrifying actually that
you did that so I mean she's going an
election I'm not sure she's an election
denier I would check on that
okay there you go this is a warning to
all the other GOP candidates
it doesn't matter how much they like you
it doesn't matter how much you do to try
to earn some favor with the liberal
press they will always turn on you
that phrase that Joy Behar said at the
beginning it's like Invasion of the Body
Snatchers this is what you always hear
sometimes for some of the Republicans
who the libs like or at least pretend to
like while those Republicans are serving
their purposes saying certain liberal
things attacking certain conservative
candidates
the moment that you pose any kind of
threat to them
they will say oh this person's totally
changed this person's totally the libs
love Mitt Romney now because Mitt
Romney's a big squish and he he parrots
their talking points
then the libs loved Mitt Romney
before 2008
after he was governor of Massachusetts
before he was a republican nominee
back when he was taking on some of the
other Republicans in 2008 the libs
really liked him and then he got the
nomination for the GOP and then he posed
a threat to Barack Obama and then he was
a monster he was he was Patrick Bateman
he was trying to kill gay boys in high
school do you remember that thing they
said he cut the hair of a homosexual
teenager or something oh and the dog he
tried to torture his dog on the family
car and they'll just and that's what
they're doing now to Nikki Haley
who Nikki Haley
was a somewhat Centrist kind of governor
in South Carolina then she worked for
the Trump Administration but she managed
to have decent support among the
moderates and also among Trump
supporters
then she came out against Trump after
the administration after January 6th and
then she but then she defended Trump
again and so she's she's
done actually a relatively decent job of
maintaining some kind of support
uh in different quarters but not but not
very intense support which is why you're
not seeing her jump up in the polls to
the position of Iran DeSantis or Donald
Trump right now
but she should be one of the more
acceptable people to the view if for no
other reason that that she is a woman
and the view is a show about empowering
women and yet
they see Nikki Haley she's running to be
the GOP nominee okay she's dead to us
she's crazy it's Invasion of the Body
Snatchers no more strange no respect
now despite the lackluster economy maybe
maybe in spite of it
the daily wire is thriving
not only that we're hiring we are
currently looking for a senior financial
analyst to join our growing Financial
Planning and Analysis team who will play
a critical role in developing actionable
insights at a rapid Pace to inform key
decisions this person will get the
opportunity to be a key player in
helping to shape the daily wires FP a
processes working closely with senior
leaders of our finance team more than
two years experience of relevant finance
and fpna corporate development
investment analysis or Investment
Banking are required the ideal candidate
also has strong interpersonal skills
with the ability to work
cross-functionally as well as Advanced
Financial modeling skills in Excel the
position is based in Nashville Tennessee
for more information and to apply go to
dailywire.com careers that's
dailywire.com careers today
speaking of Republicans
George Santos
George Santos our favorite Republican is
back in the news
he was charged with a dog-related theft
in 2017 this according to the Washington
Examiner
representative George Santos was found
to have been charged with theft related
to Amish dog breeders
in 2017.
are the Amish known for I know they're
known for their cabinets and their Barns
and their I didn't know they were known
for dog breeding the charges were
dropped though and his record was
expunged
a lawyer friend of Santos
who helped him with the charge told
Politico about the revelation
it was then confirmed by representative
from York County district court in
Pennsylvania
he was charged with theft by deception
but he beat the charge and had that
record expunged he claimed his checkbook
had been stolen and that the fifteen
thousand one hundred twenty five dollars
in checks were not written by him but
now some people say he was lying
and after the checks were addressed to
the Amish dog breeders Santa's held a
large adoption event with his animal
rescue charity friends of pets United at
the Staten Island pet store pet Oasis
and and
I don't know and I don't know and I
don't and I don't really care I've said
it before about George Santos
George Santos to me his political
success is like a bad joke
a bad joke starts out
a little tiny bit funny
and then the more you tell it it becomes
much much less funny
but then paradoxically the more you tell
it
be much much much much much funnier it
becomes
that's how I feel about Santos Santos
gets elected you say hey all right we
got a republican here elected in New
York we got a razor thin majority
already this is this is cool he's got
he's obviously a squish but you know
whatever it's fine
that's fine oh um overall net positive
and then you find out oh he lied about
his education oh that's good no he's a
liar that's too bad only lied about his
employment history oh that's too bad oh
and he he might not even be a gay guy he
might he might have been married to a
woman and which I guess is more
traditional I guess that's kind of a
maybe that ticks him up a little bit and
then he got divorced and I was
pretending to be a gay guy and or he
maybe is I don't know and oh and he lied
about his uh criminal record maybe oh
and he lied about his political
positions oh and he lied about okay
we're back it's fine and he might be
under indictment in Brazil oh this is
getting funnier again oh and he lied
about Amish dog breeding and okay this
is really
really funny at this point
there isn't pretty much nothing that
George Santos could do
that would make me demand that he
resigned because it's all out there and
this is by the way
probably the main argument for Trump in
2024. the main argument against Trump in
2024 is that he's got so much baggage
and there are lots of people who just
don't like him and he turns a lot of
people off and that's that
strong argument
but the argument for Trump in 2024 is
also
he's got so much baggage
and we know about it and it's all out
there and they throw in the kitchen sink
at him and they've made up a bunch of
stuff about them and it's been proven to
have been made up about him and
it is what it is for the other
candidates
we don't know how much real baggage
they've got we don't know
what new baggage the libs are going to
invent about them
we don't know how resilient they're
going to be in the face of that
I am real some people think that I'm
pushing Trump and that I've actually
made a decision I'm endorsing Trump in
2020. that is not the case I am it might
seem more that way when I talk about it
because I haven't picked one of the
other candidates to go sign up on the
campaign for I am just trying to call it
like I see it okay I'm not saying one of
these two options is better than the
other the case for or against Trump the
only point I'm making is it's the same
case
it's the same argument and you're seeing
it at an extreme degree in George Santos
George Santos is not going to really be
pressured to step down the more that the
the Press attack him actually the more
that it helps him
the more that you see those press
squabbles all around him screaming
yelling it makes Republicans like him
more even if Republicans look at him
they say there's like almost nothing
about you that I like as a politician
you're pretty much a squish you you're
obviously a liar
you can't be trusted what's it but
the fact that the the libs are gunning
for him so much it will increase his
support
and you will see similar phenomena play
out at the presidential level as well
speaking of crimes this is a strawman to
get to last week and I didn't have time
to do it
Marilyn Manson
the the famous rock star
uh Satanist weirdo guy is accused of
sexually assaulting a 16 year old on a
tour bus and threatened to kill that
woman's family this apparently in the
1990s so it was a long time ago I know
with a lot of these stories when they
just happened to come out 30 years later
it it makes us all a bit skeptical of it
especially because a lot of these people
are just seeking money and they're you
know at different points in their life
you say why didn't why didn't the story
come out sooner
in this story though I think Marilyn
Manson actually had talked about it in
the past I think in a different time in
a different era Marilyn Manson kind of
bragged about some of these things I I'm
I don't have anything really to say
about the story other than
it's always the ones you most expect
telling me
that the Satanist rock star who is
infamously weird about his sex and there
are all sorts of weird rumors about his
sexuality is kind of bizarrely
androgynous and he dresses up like a
demon and he flaunts his immorality
you're telling me that guy might have
done some weird bad stuff
oh man if you can't trust the demon
looking Satanist rock stars who can you
trust these days
so it really often is the ones that you
most expect you see this in the culture
now in the whole culture when you see
some weirdo usually dressed up like a
demon usually with lots of weird sexual
Hang-Ups show up to a drag queen Story
Hour show up to a middle school and then
you find out oh actually this person has
a criminal record
sexually abusing children
you look at that you say well what did
you think was going to happen
we actually our perceptions
tell us a lot of things about the real
world I know in our in our modern
culture we're told don't believe your
eyes don't believe
don't believe what you feel in your gut
don't believe your prejudices there's
nothing worse than prejudice
but actually all of those things are
essential to making any judgment
whatsoever to to acting in life at all
Prejudice not in the sense of an unjust
bigotry but Prejudice in the sense of
going along about your life making
pre-judgments is essential to getting
along in the world this is one of the
one of the most important aspects of
politics according to uh conservative
philosopher like Edmund Burke this is
part of the conservative
mind we you have to prejudge you need
Prejudice you need to be able to trust
your sensory perceptions at least to
some degree
things often are what they seem you can
very often not always but you can very
often judge a book by its cover and
speaking of satanism
want to just Spike the football on this
a little bit we talked all last week
about the the Grammy show with Sam Smith
dancing around like a like a big lesbian
devil and then all of the people in the
audience including the first lady just
go find just so
thrilled to give you all sorts of
planets
the numbers are in
that Grammys was a ratings catastrophe
the the total viewers was 12.4 Million
to put that in perspective just three
years ago the Grammys Drew 18.7 million
viewers and at the time that was
considered a ratings disaster
18.7 million is 50 percent higher than
this last Grammys Awards
what does it tell you it tells you what
happens when you make a deal with the
devil often when people make a deal with
the devil it doesn't seem quite so on
the nose as what Sam Smith did you're
usually not dancing around as an actual
devil but the thing about the Faustian
bargain the thing about the deal with
the Devil is you think all right I'm
going to do this immoral action but it's
going to get me a lot of money and then
I won't have to do immoral actions
anymore or I'm gonna I'm gonna Commit
This immoral action but it's gonna get
me my career
you know it's the casting couch in
Hollywood or it's marrying for for
ignorable reasons or it's committing
some crime you know I don't know you're
you're raskalnikov and crime and
punishment you take the ax to the poor
old lady's head but then you're not
gonna have to worry about it anymore and
you but the thing is
the deal with the devil one is never
worth it it's never worth trading your
soul for anything but two
the deal with the devil doesn't even
work out in this life
that's the joke of it all you don't end
up getting the thing that you want
things go terribly wrong not only in the
Hereafter but in this life too
can you make the deal with the devil
you're Sam Smith a generally sort of
charming British musician and then you
say okay I'm gonna sell out and become a
Satanist and that's going to revive my
career and then but actually no the
Grammy says we're gonna have a devil
performance sponsored by Pfizer and
that's going to revive the Grammys no
it's not
it it not only compromises your
Eternal being
it doesn't even work now
50 ratings down
from just three years ago you love to
see it you'll love to see it with a
little bit of shot in Florida the rest
of the show continues now it's work
Wednesday we have got
uh some really great woke content that
producer Ben Davies insists that I react
to he thinks that will scandalize me he
thinks it will shock me very little
shocks me anymore so we'll see about
that become a member right now daily
wire.com Knowles use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign